ich habe immer das gefühl dass obwohl
ich sehr interessiert bin und ich jeden
tag schaue was gibts ja neuen ideen was
gibt es einen neuen zahlen auch was gibt
es dann noch ein nachrichten habe ich
trotzdem das gefühl dass mir ganz
wichtige dinge fehlen um wirklich ne mir
ein eigenes bild zu machen und ich
glaube dass das gefühl dass ich nicht
alleine haben mit einigen menschen teile
und unter dem großen ziel die streuung
dieses virus in der bevölkerung im griff
zu behalten oder zumindest zu reduzieren
verstehe ich dass wir unsere sozialen
kontakte einschränken müssen
ich tue es auch alle meine freunde und
meine ganze familie tut es und wenn ich
draußen bin dass ich war heute zweimal
aus ich musste einkaufen dann sehe ich
auch eigentlich vernünftige menschen und
die sich entsprechend benehmen bei dem
das langsam ankommt die den abstand
halten die nicht so tun als hätte das
alles mit ihnen nichts zu tun also ich
denke es zeigt schon eine gewisse
wirkung
aber es bleiben fragen offen
es bleiben fragen offen gestern hat
angela merkel zur nation gesprochen hat
damit natürlich auch versucht viele
menschen zu beruhigen sie haben wie alle
anderen in diesem land sehr genau
hingehört was ist danach ihr fazit
gewesen hat angela merkel ihre fragen
zumindest zum teil beantworten können
nein hat sie nicht und ich glaube aber
auch nicht dass man das unbedingt von
ihr jetzt hätte erwarten müssen es gibt
sicher einige politische antworten die
eine regierung in so einer situation
dann zu geben hat und das war gestern
nicht der fall es war ja mehr eine etwas
allgemeiner gehaltenen rede ans an unser
volk also auch an mich ich habe nichts
neues gehört ich habe nichts gehört was
ich jetzt nicht auch schon von anderen
gehört hätte wenn es wenig fachfragen
habe dann würde ich sie auch lieber an
fachleute stellen von denen ich weiß die
familien tag damit zu tun sie hat
letztlich das war das einzige was so was
so ein bisschen halb konkret im raum
stand dann noch gesagt ist so ein
bisschen als gespenst dann die
ausgangssperre noch im raum steht
von der ja auch viele wissenschaftler
sagen dass sie eigentlich keinen nutzen
bringt und keinen sinn macht was sich
draußen bei wind und wetter eigentlich
in der regel niemand ansteckt solange
gruppenbildungen verhindert werden
solange es leute nicht warum kreise
bilden posten beim tanzen oder bei einer
party im tag also das haben glaube ich
alle verstanden dass die korona parties
der schwachsinn sind schwachsinn sind
wenn man sie unter diesem zehnter dieser
ziele stecken betrachtet diese kurve der
ansteckung eben ein bisschen flacher zu
kriegen heißt im moment verläuft aber
ansonsten der gedanke an eine
ausgangssperre tatsächlich also ist ja
sowas wie stubenarrest sorgen dass ich
auch glaube ich nicht gut vielleicht
auch nicht mal sind was genau hat ihnen
gefehlt an den worten die angela merkel
gefunden hat es gibt sicher
viele sorgen die menschen gerade haben
und eine davon ist wie geht's weiter mit
ihrem mit ihrem leben wie kann man
wieder geld verdienen also ich bin
arbeite wahrscheinlich jeder weiß
inzwischen beim beim film aber arbeitet
auch als musiker das ist der ort wo ich
meine familie mein geld verdiene und
dort steht eigentlich alles still es
wurde alles abgesagt und alle filmdrehs
und gestoppt und wenn man vielleicht
fähnchen in einem film der dem man
gerade gedreht hat eine hauptrolle
gespielt hat und hat man noch ein
bisschen geld übrig und behalten und das
ist vielleicht nicht so der große sorge
aber es gibt im filmgeschäft sehr viele
andere leute es gibt leute die im team
arbeiten es gibt fahrer es gibt leute
die machen das catering es gibt
beleuchter es gibt kamera assistenten
und all das und für die sieht anders aus
und da gibt es große auch existenzielle
fragen
da habe ich gar nichts gehört es gibt
momentan keinen richtigen alltag aber
für viele viele deutsche gehört
natürlich der tatort am sonntag einfach
fest dazu und gerade jetzt wäre es ja
wichtig so strukturen irgendwie noch zu
haben
wie geht es jetzt in nächster zeit mit
dem tatort direkt weiter eine gute frage
an die ard oder in meinem fall denn an
den wdr also wir haben was den
münster-tatort angeht kann ich sagen wir
haben einen abgedreht der ist da ja
schon richtig fertig ist und -fähig weiß
ich nicht verdienen gibt es immer mein
glaube ich so weit ich weiß keinen
sendetermin avatar lege eine auf alle
was ist nur ein einziger sonntag den wir
da irgendwie decken könnten der nächste
tatort er gedreht werden sollte ist erst
mal auf unbestimmte zeit verschoben
sie haben auch gesagt sie versuchen
distanz zu möglichst vielen leuten zu
halten wie sie bei ihnen jetzt ein
tagesablauf aus zu dieser zeit
wahrscheinlich nicht anders als in
anderen familien auch ich setze hier
jetzt gerade in dieser bisschen aussieht
wie ein opel werk ist nur ein studio
da sitze ich arbeite ein bisschen an
musik neue ideen für neue songs sind so
langsam auf und schreibt über text ich
verbringe zeit mit meiner familie hier
kochen zusammen hatte für uns zusammen
gegessen wir sind im moment alle zu
hause alle halten sich auch daran dass
die stimme gut wir haben das selten dass
wir so zusammen sind wie jetzt gerade
und versuchen das beste draus zu machen
und die sache eher etwas positives zu
sehen aber wenn man natürlich so ein
bisschen weiter denkt dann ist das was
im hintergrund gerade abläuft er schwer
als etwas positives zu sehen irgendwie
hat man das gefühl die katze ist noch
nicht ganz aus dem sagt man hat das
gefühl ist es gibt sehr düstere
prognosen die prognosen sind aber auch
alle zum teil widersprüchlich sie sie
bei serien letztlich auf annahmen keine
hat erfahrung mit der situation des
gebrechen modelle bei den
wissenschaftlern die sehen etwas
günstiger aus es gibt welche die gehen
ganz schrecklich aus alle krankenhäuser
bereiten sie sich vor wenn es bei dieser
gelegenheit werde ich das auch noch mal
sagen also dass die menschen in den
krankenhäusern die krankenschwestern das
medizinisch technische personal was die
ärzte dass alle dort zu leisten haben
ist unglaublich und am ende des tages
geht es mir ist hoch ich bin jetzt
schauspieler geworden natürlich will ich
mache ein bisschen musik und können
davon gut leben aber eine situation wie
dieser frage ich mich was nicht auch gut
gewesen
vielleicht medizin zu studieren dann
könnte müsste ich jetzt nicht hier
sitzen sondern könnte irgendwo sinnvoll
helfen 89 auch stark für ihre freiheit
gekämpft sind auf die straße gegangen
wie sehen sie jetzt also den einschnitt
in so viele unserer ja eigentlich
grundrechte tatsächlich
naja ok das ist tatsächlich eine
schwierige frage ich natürlich regt sich
erst mal bei mir ein protest wenn ich
lese dass unsere bewegungsprofile von
der deutschen telekom
hans robert koch-institut einfach jetzt
mal so weitergegeben werden sie werden
anonymisiert so heißt es aber das ist
natürlich schon erstmal kasten da wurde
niemand gefragt und man muss das jetzt
ein verschlucken andererseits ist es
natürlich so dass ich jetzt schon noch
den unterschied sehe es ist kein
totalitäres regime das versuchte herum
zu spitzeln aber am ende fällt hier eine
freiheit ja und ich gehe davon aus und
auch verstärkt dass das nur
vorübergehend ist und dass das nicht als
eine breche angesehen wird die dann
nachher wenn sagen wir mal alles
ausgestanden ist einfach als
selbstverständlichkeit weiter existiert
und eben viele fragezeichen über diesen
dingen weil mein kopf ich meine
letztlich eine ausgangssperre auch
einschränkungen von freiheit eigentlich
der wichtigsten freiheit der freiheit
sich frei zu bewegen haben
wenn es dann wirklich einen sinn macht
wenn das wirklich medizinisch angezeigt
ist wenn es wirklich der eindämmung
einer epidemie in seinem land doch
letztlich anderen ländern dient wenn es
zur rettung von menschenleben dient dann
bitte ich sehe zum beispiel auch so ich
weiß das kann man nicht direkt
vergleichen aber 19 2017 2018 erinnert
euch erschreckende zahlen 25.100
menschen sind damals an der influenza
gestorben in deutschland neu deutschen
und ich kann mich nicht erinnern dass
das damals auch nur ein zehntel von dem
staub aufgewirbelt hat den wir jetzt
sehen dass sie uns ihre einschätzungen
auch erzählt haben wie sie jetzt in
corona alltag bei sich zumindest
organisieren vielen dank